je vais avoir le plus joli des petits
bancs
à sept mois julie meyer mais comme si
toi tu y as tu une lettre pour toi bon
pas de tuer factor maintenant mais non
seulement comme je venais ici le facteur
nous l'a confié bon très bien et coûtent
pose là ici je la dirai tout à l'heure
il faut que je termine mon banc regarde
oui mais tu ferais bien aussi de mettre
un peu d'ordre comment mais il n'y a pas
de désordre voyant je rangeais la
semaine dernière bon bah je préfère ne
pas discuter je vais prendre le livre
que léonard m'a laissé et je repars dans
mon cas mon gars m'en tiens tu devrais
prendre exemple sur lui ça m'allait si
bien rangée qu'elle al'air deux fois
plus grande aux banques évidemment quand
il n'est pas là
enfin après tout c'est ta maison au
revoir au revoir
bon je terminerai ce banc tout à l'heure
j'aurais quand même lire cette lettre
maintenant voyons
on essaie c'est une lettre dont de mon
cousin hippolyte ça c'est formidable
alors c'était la chance parce que c'est
mon cousin préférées ouais il est timide
mais alors il est vraiment très gentil
hein mon cher casimir on sent encore
déjà ils m'aiment bien n'est ce pas je
viens d'avoir la visite d'un autre
cousin albéric il m'a raconté son séjour
dans l'île aux enfants cela m'a donné
envie de venir te voir je prendrai donc
le bateau dès demain donc aux un iep au
litre mais c'est formidable ça il va y
vont arriver mais c'est aujourd'hui
oh là là il m'a maison et dans un
désordre épouvantable
julie a dit qu'il y avait beaucoup plus
de place que d'habitude dans la malle de
léonard je crois que c'est l'endroit
idéal
voyons voyons
up et voilà c'est facile ranger
hop hop
le bon tant pis se terminera demain
hop
les voilà
[Musique]
dans la vie je vais te conter une
histoire du clown
clown colons qui s'appelle coquelicot on
lui donne une claque
ça le rend pathak pour lui donne un
baiser
il tourne deux côtés
il tombe sur un an ça lui fait une
pensent ils tombent dans le feu ça lui
fait des bleus où le look nude ou là ça
fait mal j'ai les yeux qui moulent comme
une grenouille
pourrait bien ça suffit moi je vais
chercher mon arrivage de jouer au port
enfin julie du tu vas pas faire ça à
casimir enfin au téléphone lui avons
promis que nous serions là tous les deux
pour l'attendre d'ailleurs il va pas
tarder à l'orge a pas encore 5 minutes
mais pas plus à maintien
justement
c'est pas trop tôt salut mon rôle avait
plus personne non wafa monsieur 19 qui
est venu acheter quelques nougat tout à
l'heure ah bah tant mieux j'ai eu par un
j contre rien de quoi avait eu peur
qu'ils aient mis en danger non non pas
du tout mais bon vous souvenez dans la
façon dont vous avez accueilli mon
cousin hype et mon cousin américain oh
oui gens j'en rougis encore deux ans
nous étions tellement persuadé que
c'était toi qui lui faisaient face
je me souviens jurés lancé des confettis
plein de poudre à éternuer de toile à
gratter et moi je lui avais fait voir à
un verre d'huile de foie de morue cet
astre et bien c'est justement dans sa
range erreur
j'attends mon cousin hippolyte il va
arriver d'un instant à l'autre un autre
cousin huawei qui ne soit pas inquiet
casimir maintenant nous sommes sûr que
tu as vraiment des cousins alors nous
allons très bien recevoir témoin je
crois qu'après avoir fait un long voyage
il aura certainement envie de manger un
très bon gloubiboulga bon ça c'est fait
très bonne idée alors rien qu'on leur
parle et ça me donne est quasi meilleur
tu as toujours faim toi mais cette fois
ce gloubiboulga c'est pour hippolyte
mais justement il a horreur de manger
celà alors je ne demande rien mais il
faut bien que de nous trois se sacrifie
pour
ses bons casimir qui a gagné nous
préparons un gloubi boulga pour deux
mois casimir temps le nom un peu de lui
bree est il aussi timide qu'elle berry
je crois que c'est là le plus gentil
mais aussi le plus timide tous les quasi
mary ça alors que je vous en rien soyez
très gentil avec lui il saura tellement
intimidées sinon occasion tu crois que
nous l'impressionnant ont beaucoup nous
sommes pas tellement intimidant pourtant
vous peut-être pas mais n'oubliez pas
qu'il est venu voir la vedette de la
famille a
toujours aussi simple qu'elle vive
voix la casinière s'est terminé tu veux
goûter ans je veux bien oui
non délicieux mais attends ils attendent
un enfant curieux bout il faudra quand
jean groupe une majeure en question il a
varié rester pour hippolyte voyons vous
achetez ou
vous avez entendu compo quasi mais c'est
mon cousin polita auront ils une dolman
timide qui n'osent même pas se montrer
casimiri poli et la rue ici ici par la
voile à paris si kazim tu chauffes la
chauffe là tu brûles dubrulle dans mon
cher ghazi me
vois la descente
enfin un bon voyage aux excellents bien
par là je vais te présenter à mes amis
françois et julie il tenait un grand
plaisir en lui la note pourrait bien
maintenant que les présentations sont
faites nous allons manger leurs données
bouldin quasiment tué un chef nous
sommes même pas serré la main bon c'est
vrai en plus moi je voudrais respecter
les coutumes locales
qu'est ce que c'est que ça les coutumes
locales de casimir tous ses biens les
coutumes des coutumes ce sont des
habitudes propres des coutumes locales
voilà et albéric mais a expliqué toutes
celles d'ici un an ouais bon d'accord
bien mon cousin hippolyte il
souhaiterait respecter les coutumes
locales à jean le calvez
merci de
trois et demi